I'm wearing a Todrick shirt, I'm sitting on a WrestleMania chair, and I'm trying to have a Pinterest looking shelf behind me.
I don't know what my brand is anymore either.
Also sorry, there's a skylight there
that's doing this and so that might be bothersome.
And I just- I- I don't have time for the sun to shift. Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know,
now you know. Your life is different now. Welcome to another Q and Wednesd-A.
I went on my Facebook page (facebook.com/gracehelbig) and asked you guys for questions that you wanted answered.
So let's do it. "Opinion on this photo?" How dare you break into my house and take a photo of me getting breakfast?
I really do eat blue cake icing for breakfast sometimes.
And there's nothing wrong with that. The only thing wrong with it is that you haven't thought to do it yet, so you're welcome.
I'll work on my defense of this. "Who are you?" Your worst nightmare. Slightly awkward and pathetic adult female who's
desperate for your attention via any means of social media possible. A.k.a. a millennial. "What's for breakfast?" Sometimes cake icing,
but today I straight-up had cold spaghetti. The only thing wrong with it
is that you haven't thought to do this already. "Fastest way to fall asleep? Help!" Read. "Do you like bread?"
Uh. Is the Queen of England being Weekend at Bernie's?  Riddle me that. "How do you get over a creative rut?" Turn it into a creative smut.
Watch pornography. That's not the right answer, but...
Maybe. "Why Gracevember?" Because I wasn't currently giving myself enough work and anxiety. "Is Goose doin' okay?"
What are you doing?
What... "What's your opinion on people?" People are like aliens. I don't see them frequently, but I believe that they're out there.
"Can I be the first question?" Well, I f*cked that one up. "Where do you see yourself in ten years?" Older.
Not funnier. "What not to do on the first date?"
Sh*t.
Anywhere but in a toilet. "Why didn't I buy more beer?" Because you hate yourself.
"Do you eat ass?" Is the queen being Weekend of Bernie's?
*regret*
"What should I paint?" Your feelings. No, that's eat. Paint food.
"Where do babies come?" From poor decision-making. "How's doing Gracevember been so far?" Not the worst, solid medium.
What do you guys think? "What's your favorite vodka and why?" I primarily like Tito's, but if I'm feeling nasty
I get some silly blueberry. "Goose or goose?" Goose.
"Harry or Zayn? Be careful." Oh what a pleasant threat. Guys, I'm a hairy girl.
And I also prefer Mr. Styles. Sorry, and also: Come on.
"How do you get comfortable in a long flight when you have a middle seat?" You just fart it out. You're allowed.
You've the middle seat. It's kind of a silent-
understanding that the middle seat gets to fart all they want to. "What are some good self help reads (or listens?) on audiobook right now?"
Grace's guide the art of pretending to be an adult. It is the first one that comes to mind. "Grace,
what do you do if you want to encourage your boyfriend to follow his dreams, but still pay half the rent slash bills?"
I always go for a passive aggressive
encouragement that builds a strong resentment over time for him, that leads to a complicated and messy breakup.
"If you could say one thing to Goose that she would understand,
what would you say to her?" Please let other humans pet you and not feel constantly threatened, unless I say otherwise. Thank you.
"What was the weirdest thing you thought about when you were a kid?"
I really thought that there was a Tyrannosaurus outside my window one night, after seeing Jurassic Park for the first time. And it wasn't
doing anything, it was just looking, but it was horrifying.
And I slept on the floor of my parents' bedroom. "If you could trade places with any youtuber for a week, who would it be and why?"
Probably Lilly Singh, she's doing life right.
She just- she made choices, and it's working out and I want to see that firsthand. "Apart from being an amazing comedian
what do you hope to be doing/get done in 2018?" I hope to get some shows going. Either scripted series, or live
performances, that would be nice.
"How do you handle being a socially awkward person and make guy friends?" Find socially awkward guys to be friends with, like aliens.
They're out there. "I am not a new subscriber, but can you mention me anyway in next vid?" You got it, Shakti.
"How do you feel about being near the full release of the Taylor Swift album?" Buthole...
Unclenched. "Do you ever just stay in bed all day, because you just can't face the cruel world out there?"
Oh yeah, it's cute for like a day, and then it's you-  You gotta, you gotta
get out of this place. "Is it acceptable to nap at work?" If you work in a sleep monitoring clinic.
"I've asked this lots of times. What's your Myers-Briggs personality?"
I'm an INFP on the Myers-briggs personality test scale. Sometimes called the mediator, for those of you that are familiar.
"I'm celebrating Thanksgiving with my boyfriend's family this year. Any advice on topics for conversation?"
Religion, politics,
sexuality. You'll either be kicked out or
will have left on your own accord probably, by the end of those three topics
covered. "When is your membership to team 10 going to be approved?" It's like one of my non-favorite party games:
Forever in limbo. "If you can redesign the shape of a hotdog, what shape would you mold it into for everyone to enjoy?" She's
perfect as it's.
"I love your cooking videos. Is there going to be a
Thanksgiving food video." If you guys want it, leave comments down below if you want some sort of
Thanksgiving food cooking video thing of sorts and stuff.
Maybe... "How excited are you to meet me at the live Not too Deep podcast on Saturday in New York City?"
So excited! For those of you that don't know, we're doing Not too Deep live in New York City this Saturday.
Link for tickets is in the description below.
Please, come. Buy
Y=your tickets Iliza Shlesinger is our guest and the first 100 people that show up to the theater are getting a free
meet-and-greet with Jack and I after the show. So please, please, please buy your tickets.
There's not many left, so click and go. Okay, that's it for this Q and Wendnesd-A.
I hope you guys enjoyed it. If you did, give this video a thumbs up and click subscribe on this YouTube channel.
Because I'm making videos Monday through Friday through the month of Gracevember. You don't want to miss it. It's not the worst.
I don't know.
"How does Goose feel about the current state of the world?" Goose, what do you think about the current state of the world?
Same.